Narrator: THE CREW ON BOARD
THE VIRGINIA CLASS
WILL EXPERIENCE SEEMINGLY
NORMAL LIVING CONDITIONS,
BUT THEY'LL BE UP TO 800 FEET
BELOW THE OCEAN,
SO SAFETY IS A TOP PRIORITY.
EVERY POSSIBILITY
MUST BE PREPARED FOR.
Nabors: IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
OF A SUBMARINE SINKING,
WE DEFINITELY HAVE
THE CAPABILITY TO ESCAPE.
Narrator:
IN CASE A SUB'S INTERNAL
ATMOSPHERE IS EVER COMPROMISED,
CHIEF WARRANT OFFICER
ERIC NABORS
TRAINS THE CREW TO PERFORM
A PRESSURIZED ESCAPE,
USING AN INGENIOUS PIECE
OF EQUIPMENT
CALLED A SEIE SUIT.
Nabors: IT'S DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
THE OCCUPANT FRESH BREATHING AIR
THROUGH THE COMPRESSION
AND ASCENT PHASES.
IT PROVIDES 75 POUNDS OF
POSITIVE BUOYANCY IN THE WATER.
IT TRAVELS
AT 625 FEET PER MINUTE
THROUGH THE WATER COLUMN.
TOPSIDE, REQUEST PERMISSION
TO FILL AND EQUALIZE.
Man: YOU HAVE PERMISSION
Narrator: AS THE REGULATED
LIFTING FORCE OF THE SUIT
PROPELS THE STUDENTS
SAFELY THROUGH
THE 37-FOOT ESCAPE TRAINER,
THEY MUST FOLLOW
ONE GOLDEN RULE.
THE NUMBER-ONE RULE
OF SUBMARINE ESCAPE IS NEVER,
EVER HOLD YOUR BREATH.
BECAUSE THE ESCAPEE IS BREATHING
COMPRESSED GAS AT DEPTH,
WHEN THEY TRAVEL THROUGH
THE WATER COLUMN,
THE PRESSURE
AROUND THEM DECREASES.
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH PULMONARY
OVER-INFLATION SYNDROME.
Narrator: THIS POTENTIALLY FATAL
CONDITION CAN CAUSE THE RUPTURE
OF AIR SACS
IN A CREW MEMBER'S LUNGS.
Nabors: IF A STUDENT
WERE TO HOLD THEIR BREATH,
THAT WOULD OCCUR, SO WE TEACH
THEM TO BREATHE NORMALLY
OR EXHALE THE ENTIRE WAY
TO THE SURFACE.
ARE YOU OKAY?
I'M OKAY.
Narrator: IN OPEN WATER,
THE SEIE SUIT CAN WITHSTAND
UP TO 250 POUNDS OF PRESSURE
PER SQUARE INCH.
THESE SUITS HAVE BEEN TESTED
TO DEPTHS UP TO 600 FEET
OF SEAWATER.
THE SEIE SUIT ITSELF IS AN
INCREDIBLE PIECE OF ENGINEERING.